por primera vez en francia un ministro
de justicia frente a una corte de la
república un año después de asumir su
cargo
eric to por moretti fue convocado ante
los jueces por un posible conflicto de
intereses se cree que se habría
aprovechado de su posición con susto de
justicia para figurar cuentas con tres
magistrados de la fiscalía financiera
nacional ordenando una investigación
administrativa contra ellos los tres
magistrados son señalados de haber
utilizado los registros telefónicos de
varios abogados y magistrados durante
seis años
con la meta de identificar a la persona
que filtró a nicolas sarkozy y su
defensor
thierry el shock que estaban siendo
monitoreados por un caso de corrupción
uno de los abogados monitoreados era
precisamente eric tu pon moretti este
viernes tú pon moretti fue convocado un
primer interrogatorio que podría derivar
en cargos por abuso de poder
insiste en que el ministro sólo estaba
siguiendo las recomendaciones de su
despacho
con moretti denunció un uso de la
justicia por parte de los sindicatos
para removerlo del ministerio
considerando que la separación de
poderes está en riesgo dos diputados
anunciaron su dimisión de la corte de
justicia de francia